the opposite of madness is not
necessarily reason but sanity and sanity
can be produced by quite simple things
creative people say this this voice is
talking to me this inner voice is
telling me things the person with the
psychosis hears a voice they look around
they don't see them they search for them
psychosis is related to people's life
stories there is a story about
neurochemicals like dopamine i think
that it's very important it's part of
the story
the madness of one epoch may become the
sanity of the next and the pages of
history are littered with great artists
and innovators who were deemed mad when
they first explored their ideas
so might madness be a form of wisdom
rather than its diseased opposite
or is it a medical condition that needs
to be defined and treated
so here to discuss this we have a very
fascinating panel on my right we have
robert rowland smith who is quandom
fellow of all souls college oxford
he's also a consultant lecturer and
writer in philosophy literature and
psychoanalysis and robert's books
include death drive and breakfast with
socrates
here we have on the far left patricia
casey who's professor of psychiatry and
author of seven books
related to mental health patricia's main
focus is on adjustment disorders and
spreading mental health awareness in her
column mind and meaning in the irish
independent and here is richard bentle
who's professor of clinical psychology
at the university of liverpool and
author of madness explained and
doctoring the minds and he researches in
particular childhood trauma psychosis
and public mental health
so i'm sure many of you are aware of the
format already but i'll just briefly go
through it we have a three-minute pitch
from each of our discussants where they
advance their main contentions and then
we go through to a debate divided
roughly into three parts
when i was invited onto this panel i
thought uh straight away of this famous
spat in the 1960s between michel
foucault and jacques derrida michel
foucault had written this book called
history of madness
and daredevil said well there's a basic
problem with writing a history of
madness because a history of madness is
a rational project
right it's a it's a it's a reason-based
project
to write about madness and derrida's
argument is well if there is such a
thing as madness it will always escape
any rational account of it so there's a
kind of in-principle difficulty in even
beginning to talk about
madness because you are
cladding it about with rational
structures you're giving a conceptual
architecture which if it's mad it will
always somehow escape so
um i think that's a kind of general
protocol to put into this debate you
know can we ever touch this thing called
madness using reason after all this
panel is based on
reason this is a reason debate about
madison reason not a mad debate about
manchester united well it was pretty mad
we'll see what transpires in the next
hour so that's um i guess that's the
first thing uh to say
the next thing to say i think is that
the this
you know putting madness and reason as
complete opposites um might be a bit of
a problem for various reasons but one
reason i think is to do with language
and maybe we'll talk about this a bit
today so
one of the reasons that this is a
reasonable or reason-based session is
that we understand one another in this
room right we're using the same language
and
up to a point i mean we might not
understand everything but there's a
convention that enables us to understand
one another
and it strikes me that one definition of
madness or of the mad person is the
person who can't be understood
so um
if you are i mean i do with my other hat
as a consultant a kind of business
consultant i do actually quite a lot of
work with mental health organizations
and
in some of the most kind of extreme
cases in the kind of forensic end in
high security wings
of such institutions you do get people
in those uh institutions who are not
possible to understand they're speaking
their own language they are as it were
beyond cognition or apparently beyond
cognition or recognition
by uh by
so-called sane people
but it strikes me actually if you take
one
let's use the word mad mad person
and put them together with another mad
person who speaks the same language and
those two people start conversing
question becomes well are they still mad
they're making sense to one another
you know they have a conventional
understanding they're able to
communicate in their own terms
they're making sense so is that still
madness
so i wonder if there's something about
madness which is about an absolute kind
of singularity just being in isolation
not being understood by other people at
all but as soon as you begin to be you
begin to become understood i wonder if
that begins to erase the difference
between
uh between madness and and reason and
the third thing i would like to say
again with my other hat on is
is
is i guess the question of whether it's
reason that's the opposite of madness or
sanity
so this panel could have been about
madness and sanity as opposed to madness
and reason right
and it's very interesting that
um certainly the kind of professionals i
work with in that sphere and my fellow
panelists will probably say more about
this it's interesting there's a real um
scale you know you're not either mad or
sane you know there are degrees uh
there clearly are degrees
and what's particularly interesting for
me is that there are so many things
outside of the mind that create madness
rather than things inside the mind
so certainly in these mental health
organizations that i'm working with
there are simple checklists of
indicators that lead to madness so for
example if you have a decent home
if you have a job if you have a family
and friends the chances of you
developing mental illness goes radically
down
uh than if you then if you don't have
those things so although we tend to
think of madness psychosis is kind of
internally created kind of corruption of
the brain in some way
actually in many many ways there are
very simple social structures that can
be put in place to relieve people of the
anxiety that can blow up into kind of
more extreme forms of stress and
ultimately psychosis or schizophrenia
and so on so i'm quite interested in
that idea of kind of madness that exists
outside the brain and can be you know
mitigated by very simple sensible
structures
and can remind us that actually the
opposite of madness is not necessarily
reason but sanity and sanity can be
produced by quite simple things you know
having a home
having a job having a network thank you
that's great okay i'm going to turn to
patricia casey with the same question
which is might madness be a strange form
of wisdom rather than it's diseased
i was hoping to convince you all of my
argument with this headline that i saw
on yesterday's evening standard sheep go
on psychotic rampage through welsh
village after eating cannabis plants
and i was hoping that i would head out
there with my injection my needle my
syringe inject the sheep and impress you
all by the prowess of medication to
treat these psychotic sheep
unfortunately it happened in swansea so
they're nowhere near this part of the
world and they may end up eating the
cannabis anyway
i want to tell you about some patients
because there's nothing like patients
and ill people to ground you
i'm a consultant psychiatrist i'm i see
i have a caseload of about 200 patients
and i'm on call one week in four and the
second on call my junior doctors are the
first on call they're at the cold face
and so get called two or three times
most nights about patients usually
presenting to the emergency department i
work in a general hospital
and
an example one night i was called about
a man in his forties he's well known to
me he has been a patient of mine for 18
months
he
becomes uh he he first became psychotic
when he was abusing cannabis but his
recent episodes have been independent of
cannabis
um
his his most he has always had the
following symptoms he believes that his
wife is poisoning his food and she's
only poisoning one of his foods a
particular fish that he eats not his
meat not his vegetables just his fish
how does he know that he doesn't know
how he knows that he just knows that she
is
he's had four admissions in the 18
months i've been treating him and all
except the last one were under the
mental health act
he was admitted compulsorily because of
his level of disturbance the most recent
admission occurred when he um he um told
his wife that he believed she was
poisoning his food there was a row he
hit her he ran out of the house he
walked and ran for 20 miles round the
perimeter of dublin
he was eventually the guard they were
eventually notified that this man was
behaving strangely when he tried to
cross
a six-lane motorway
running out of dublin shouting they're
coming after me they're coming after me
fortunately the traffic was was
at snail's pace because it was rush hour
the guard they were called and he was
brought into the guard the station the
police station then to
my hospital to the emergency department
and my junior doctor said to me what
will we do now i didn't think to call
the local philosopher and i didn't think
to call the local cognitive therapist
that will come later on when he's well
but at the moment he is acutely
disturbed i have to get him into
hospital and treat him
you